>> Tucker: IN FLORIDA LAST
NIGHT, DONALD TRUMP ANNOUNCED
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AGAIN, IF YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
HIS RALLIES HE'S DONE AROUND THE
COUNTRY FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS, SOME OF IT SEEMED
FAMILIAR, BUT THERE WERE PARTS
OF THE SPEECH WHERE HE OFFERED
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS THAT YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD BEFORE, AND THAT
NOBODY SEEMS TO BE TALKING
ABOUT, AT LEAST IN THE WAY HE
SPOKE ABOUT IT LAST NIGHT.
THE FENTANYL CRISIS, FOR
EXAMPLE.
HE OFFERED A PLAN TO FIX IT.
HE SAID HE WOULD WAGE WAR ON THE
DRUG CARTELS AND INSTITUTE THE
DEATH PENALTY FOR PEOPLE WHO
DEAL FENTANYL.
>> WE WILL WAGE WARS AGAINST THE
CARTELS, STOP THE FENTANYL AND
DEADLY DRUGS FROM KILLING
200,000 AMERICANS PER YEAR.
I WILL ASK CONGRESS FOR
LEGISLATION ENSURING THAT DRUG
DEALERS AND HUMAN TRAFFICKERS,
THESE ARE TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE,
HORRIBLE PEOPLE, WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEATH, CARNAGE
AND CRIME ALL OVER OUR COUNTRY.
EVERY DRUG DEALER DURING HIS OR
HER LIFE, ON AVERAGE, WILL KILL
500 PEOPLE WITH THE DRUGS THEY
SELL, NOT TO MENTION THE
DESTRUCTION OF FAMILIES.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKING
EVERYONE WHO SELLS DRUGS, GETS
CAUGHT SELLING DRUGS, TO RECEIVE
THE DEATH PENALTY FOR THEIR
HEINOUS ACTS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S INTERESTING
IDEA.
YOU MAY LIKE IT.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE IT.
YOU MAY LIKE TRUMP.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE TRUMP.
YOU COULD BE A DEMOCRAT WHO
LIVES TO DESPISE HIM.
YOU COULD BE A REPUBLICAN WHO
PREFERS RON DESANTIS.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOU THINK OF
TRUMP OR HIS POLICIES ON
FENTANYL OR ANYTHING ELSE.
IF YOU'RE AN AMERICAN, YOU HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN ORDER FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY TO FUNCTION,
POLITICAL CANDIDATES HAVE TO BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC.
IF THEY CAN'T SPEAK IN PUBLIC,
THIS CAN'T BE A DEMOCRACY BY
DEFINITION.
HERE YOU HAVE TWITTER BANNING
TRUMP.
HE'S STILL BANNED, DESPITE ELON
MUSK'S TAKEOVER, TRUMP IS STILL
BANNED FROM TWITTER TONIGHT.
PARLER WAS PULLED OFF THE
INTERNET FOR GIVING DONALD TRUMP
AN ACCOUNT.
AT THE TIME PEOPLE WERE SICK OF
TRUMP MANY MAKE HIM SHUT UP.
THERE ARE ATTACKS ON OUR SYSTEM,
ATTACKS ON DEMOCRACY.
THEY'RE ATTACKS ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF A FREE SOCIETY.
SO YOU HAVE TO WONDER NOW WHERE
ARE THE DEFENDERS OF DEMOCRACY?
PEOPLE YELLING LAST WEEK,
ACAD